bonjour marc bastide merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
en direct sur rt france c'est vrai que
le sort des retraités on n'entend pas
beaucoup parler pendant
la campagne présidentielle aujourd'hui
il y à une mobilisation nationale
pourquoi êtes-vous en colère
colère avant que vous sachiez que en ce
qui concerne l'europe c'est comme ça
qu'on l'appelle
il ya eu une première action le 31 mars
le deuxième acte sur le rotor et y
compris aujourd'hui à paris
avec trois axes essentiels pour
l'interview de ces d'organisation la
question d'augmentation de grève des
factions du monde intégration parce que
pour le free mais certains et pour le
public cette pression la question de la
protection sociale la sécurité sociale
et la question des services publics sur
trois éléments qui nous sont exemptés de
dire son la tête d'affiché des retraités
dans la période actuelle pourquoi
aujourd'hui les pensions et les
retraites elles ne sont plus suffisantes
pour pour vivre quand on est retraité
plusieurs images des
films avoir appuyé sur la question des
systèmes de robben le deuxième est mal
c'est que yes d'aller séguin qui vient
de se passer de lui un gel sur
l'augmentation des retraites voire une
pétition à 2018 avec les nourritures nos
cotisations csg quelle fut pratiquement
sûr eu l'année un mois de salaire à
l'entraînement monroe et le troisième 1
6% en a les retraites complémentaires
il ya eu le gel de la valeur du point
pendant cinq ans
avec une situation où de plus en plus
des retraités font face d'une fois
lassitude
vivre tous les jours mais dans le même
temps la
sacrifie la chaîne geod il
expliqué il ya une dimension qui n'est
pas aussi de la réflexion
pour cent mais qui est loin évidemment
de l'inflation qui est à plus de 2 5 %
aujourd'hui avec la hausse du prix des
matières premières vous ne vous en
sortez plus mais non aujourd'hui il ya
eu une augmentation mais les retraites
de base à ce qu'on appelle sécurité
sociale 024 au feu et une augmentation
des recettes complémentaires de bourse
ça fait vingt-quatre ans après vous
venez de dire en inventoriant lévitation
et de 0 6%
les accords qui sont passés depuis x
années devait
être calculé sur la base de l'inflation
la loi
d'ores et déjà que anne ne vois tu as
d'augmentation de
fidélisation il ya un déficit déjà un
portail mon deuxième élément que je
voudrais donner parce que le visuel
o'neal retraités qui sont propriété
ils ont besoin d'argent parce que
je pense que ça c'est une fausse idée on
a besoin de bien mesurer dans la
situation actuelle
comment s'est passée la vie des
retraités d'une part faut savoir qu'il
ya un million un million de retraités
fut particulièrement des pages qui sont
à 9,5 après euros par mois ensuite il ya
5 millions de retraités qui sont au
dessus de mélo ensuite il ya la base du
du déni et c'est mon deuxième élément
c'est la situation aujourd'hui
la question du coût de la vie et d'un
surcoût de la vie il ya là deux éléments
qui en chaîne
leur vie des retraités du ne pas brader
retraités qui ont encore des enfants à
charge parce qu'ils poursuivent au désir
et donc ça ça coûte le deuxième élément
pour ces mêmes ils peuvent là à voir vos
parents qui sont en perte d'autonomie
voire dans les ehpad c'est ça aussi que
c'est un goût je ne pouvais avoir des
retraités
qui poursuivent leurs études et en même
temps qu'ils voient leurs parents en
perte d'autonomie est revenu
cette tête
marque finale cher et difficile à
supporter il y en a de plus en plus de
retraités il fera face
à ce constat en un mot on arrive au
terme de cette interview qu est ce que
vous demandez vous aujourd'hui au
candidat à la présidentielle
on veut cibler on remarque entre les
usages sociaux parce que voir un coup de
chance pour nous toutes les élections
présidentielles mais on parle très peu
de social pour que ça soit chez les
actifs là on est avec les retraités il
est pas beau questionner la
manifestation futur
pour construire un compromis avec
villiers de reprêter deux appareils
venus ça veut dire que quand même de
quoi discuter et barbecue organisé des
débats etc ou encore des vidéos dvr
paris et donc c'est certain colère qui
est en train de monter sur vos genoux et
de négociation d'une augmentation des
patients le besoin et ce public y
compris je parle accès aux hôpitaux
on est en train de terminer au grenier
des urgences de nuit la pince et
l'arabité retrouvé 150 certain nombre de
questions
merci excuses et marc bastide
malheureusement le temps de poursuivre
mais merci beaucoup pour vos précisions
ce matin en direct dans la matinale
d'ayrté france